des paysages et ainsi à la perte de vue
un territoire précieux est menacée qui
accueille une partie de la fameuse
prairies d'herbes mixte un écosystème
propre aux grandes plaines d'amérique du
nord
bienvenue au parc national des prairies
l'un des joyaux de la saskatchewan
prennent de pyrrhus in se sent chez elle
ici
ok et ce n'est pas étonnant puisque sa
famille était propriétaire d'une partie
des terres jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
transformée en parc national en 2001 sa
mission protéger ce parc et le faire
connaître et pis même chose pour sa
collègue andré simard qui est originaire
de lisieux un petit village d'origine
francophone située non loin du parc
pour elle cet endroit permet aux gens de
se plonger dans une atmosphère unique
c'est parfait tu peux marcher pour
rapprocher a repris pas voir une autre
personne un endroit où selon elle on
peut se perdre pour mieux se retrouver
parce que on a besoin de ça on a besoin
d'un petit peu de pain le parc de 900
km² est divisé en deux secteurs celui de
l'est et celui de l'ouest
la portion de l'est est composé de deux
éco systèmes distincts où se rencontrent
des hautes terres et des paysages arides
bounce beats the hours la partie de
l'ouest est reconnu pour ses chiens de
prairie mais surtout pour son troupeau
de bisons qui ont été réintroduits en
2005 après une absence de plus de 120
ans
les visiteurs sont de plus en plus
nombreux même si l'endroit offre très
peu de confort à ses invités c'est pas
comme une là une vacance régulière il y
en a pas des râteaux depuis on a pas on
n'a pas des douches
certains sont prêts à faire des milliers
de kilomètres pour de visiter d'aussi
loin que de maureilhanais je pense qu'il
faut le marché pour comprendre un petit
peu c'est son sens son essence de la
prairie c'est quelque chose qui est
comme qu'on ne peut qu on connait pas
nous dans death pour cette famille de
québécois qui vivent maintenant
saskatchewan visiter le parc c'est une
façon d'en apprendre un peu plus sur
leur province d'accueil et bien entendu
sur les dinosaures qui ont peuplé cette
région auparavant
il adore surtout le fait qu'ils
pourraient avoir des facile d'aider des
os de dinosaures ce sale intéresse
beaucoup et avec tout l'historique de la
place mais c'est souvent la nuit que ces
visiteurs attendent avec le plus
d'impatience parce que le spectacle
céleste après le coucher du soleil est à
couper le souffle
c'est que le parc national des prairies
abrite la plus obscure des réserve de
ciel étoilé au pays un endroit où la
pollution lumineuse est limitée ce qui
permet de mieux observer le ciel
et quand tu vois ça en ligne qui
traverse le ciel puis et puis c cnet
qu'alex il pria ça vous donne un sens
des vraiment recette un endroit qui nous
rappelle que chacun de nous fait partie
de tout beaucoup plus grand que lui
ici nicolas vente smit radio canada au
parc national des prairies en
saskatchewan